so with the Walking Dead coming back on
tonight I figured I'd try my hand at
some Walking Dead comics I'll try this a
couple times before but you know it
really kind of received a mixed
reception but I think that now is
probably the best time to delve into
Walking Dead content due to the fact
that it's one of the most searched terms
in Google right now and if there's any
one thing that people want to know it's
who was it that negan killed in The
Walking Dead and so the answer to this
question actually takes place or comes
to us in a story called
something to fear now there are some
differences between the comic books and
the TV show and so instead of like
preface with you know at the beginning
of the video actually going to take it
as we go through things but what the
story does or what this is what the
story or Kedah is rather is it initially
opens up with basically Church and this
is designed by Robert Kirkman to tell us
that within the Alexandria safe zone
within this area assembly called
Alexandria that life goes on as normal
now
the reason why is because prior to this
story arc there was an event called a
larger world and what a larger world did
is it gave us a few things one the
leader of Alexandria was not a woman
like we saw on the TV show instead it
was a man but when Alexandria basically
fell and when Rick Grimes and his forces
were able to clear out you know all the
zombies that invaded Alexandria and kind
of go back to trying and live a normal
life as well as rebuilding it the group
was met by the arrival of a man named
Paul Monroe also known as Jesus and what
he did is he introduced them to a place
called the hilltop colony a location
that Rick Grimes and his crew were
previously unaware of now the issue with
this or I guess in the events leading up
to this particular story something to
fear there were some circumstances that
went on basically one of a member of a
group called the Savior's had been sent
to the hilltop colony for the purpose of
sending a message and in the Missis in
this message he attacked a guy named
Gregory who was the leader of the
hilltop colony and killed him now while
Rick Grimes in turn killed the attacker
and I think his name was Ethan when
everybody around the hilltop colony was
surprised up Hall Monroe spoke up and
basically told Rick Grimes that the way
the situation worked is that there is a
group called the Savior's and the
Savior's if I remember correctly are
about 200 strong and they are cold
blooded and they are ruthless
but an agreement was struck between the
hilltop colony and the savior's that as
long as the hilltop colony gave up
supplies at the demand of the saviors
but the saviors themselves would protect
the hilltop colony from bandits from
from zombie threats basically keep the
hilltop colony protected sooo it was
very much a Eloy and Morlock kind of
situation you know if you guys are
familiar with with the time machine from
HG Wells but because of the fact that
this was a situation that Rick Grimes
wasn't initially in agreement with and
because of the fact that he had killed a
member of the Savior's the Savior's as a
group view themselves as a single entity
meaning that if one person harms one of
them then that person needs to be dealt
with it's not a situation where the
Savior's simply say well one guy down it
doesn't really matter they will go after
who that person is and that's what this
does but it also gives us a few things
in terms of status quo for example at
this point in the comic books Rosita is
spending time with Eugene now the two of
them are not actually dating but Rosita
is not in a relationship with Abraham
any longer and so while Eugene kind of
uses this to mess with Abraham a little
bit at the very least it just shows us
that there's trouble in paradise with
regards to the to the team of Rosita
Eugene and and Abraham and so again this
is just kind of Robert Kirkman giving us
information showing us how things go but
we also pick up with Rick Grimes and
with Andrea now something I want to
point out here is that unlike the TV
show where Rick Grimes and Michonne are
in a relationship and the comic books
Rick Grimes and Andrea are in a
relationship this is also in stark
contrast to the TV show and that we saw
Andrea die and there weren't that many
people who were sad to see her go I
certainly was not sad to watch her die
but in the TV show the character of
Sasha is basically Andrea so in the
comics as we're going through this
imagine the personality of Sasha from
the TV show with the with the physical
body of Andrea and that's who Andrea is
here in the comics she's a 4-digit
shooter she's one of the strongest
members of the team she's actually like
the second-in-command to Rick Grimes and
of course the two of them are also
lovers but on their journey they're met
by the arrival of you know of Dwight
basically they're met by the arrival of
the forces of negan now when when they
initially show up this is one of the
first times that Rick Grimes really
knows who negan is or at least seems to
understand who negan is and this is a
huge difference from the TV
because in TV show it was a great big
huge long drawn-out part of the the
second half really of the season to
reveal who it was that negan is who you
know is axe behind the scenes and so on
and so forth in the comics it's not that
way the reason why is because once these
forces immediately demand you know what
it is a Rick Grimes has the forces of
his of his group opened fire and they
immediately start taking out you know
all these areas people they start
slaughtering them left and right and so
while they do go into retreat all this
does is make things worse and so when
they head back when they get back to the
to the Alexandria safe zone the question
is what should they do I mean they have
all these supplies they have all these
things that they need but they also know
that a conflict is looming on the
horizon now this also is Robert Kirkman
setting the stage for the death of a
major character in the sense that we see
a lot of them coming together we see of
course you know Maggie revealing to
Glenn that she's pregnant we have Rick
Grimes sort of speaking to the entire
you know congregation or the entire
group as a whole telling them that with
the hilltop colony with you know because
of the fact that you know things seem to
be getting darker that times are going
to be getting harder it also shows us
you know that Rick Grimes and Andrea are
starting to get into more of a
relationship you know that the two of
them have their own issues in terms of
trust they have their own issues in
terms of how it is they're working
together but at the same time the idea
is they're going to become something
more serious now again picking up and
continuing on we know that that Abraham
and Eugene essentially join forces or I
guess they come together for a recon
mission at the request of Rick Grimes
but in the midst of this Abraham is
suddenly shot through the head with an
arrow now this takes Eugene completely
by surprise but remember in the comic
books much like the TV show Eugene is
basically a coward there are a couple
instances when he stands up and he
suddenly has skills or he develops a
backbone but 90% of the time he's very
weak now the arrival of the forces of
negan really don't tell us exactly what
it is that's going on with you know with
with Eugene but what we do know is that
almost immediately after he's captured
he's taken before the Alexandria save
some and immediately you know the forces
of negan start opening fire in terms of
you know issuing warning shots and
letting people know that they're there
now Eugene is able to make his escape by
biting the crotch of
by day the crotch of one of negan's guys
which is kind of weird but it's him
making his escape Rick Grimes also comes
to the rescue and then we have Andrea
taking potshots with a sniper rifle so
again they're basically killing off the
forces of negan every single time they
get into an encounter and it sends the
forces of negan running for the hills
and again this is basically just a
scenario where things keep going from
bad to worse for Rick Grimes and this is
something that I hope you take note of
here because in this situation Rick
Grimes is showing himself to be fearless
he is worried a little bit in terms of
what happens next you know when these
when these guys take off and they say
negan is going to kill you [ __ ] going
to kill all of you it does raise some
questions of what's what comes next what
happens next but Rick Grimes does not
seem to be extremely concerned here
instead he seems to be kind of blowing
things off and not really worrying about
it and so what this does is it sort of
segues into various members of the camp
kind of concerned about the direction
things are taking sort of worried about
the direction things are taking we see
Eugene and Rosita dealing with the death
of Abraham which was actually pretty
sudden it was a real shocker there's of
course a meeting with everybody in terms
of the church and people talking about
the passing of a couple members of their
group and so it's basically just sort of
an in-between kind of a lull period with
everybody coming to an understanding of
what it is us going on and the direction
that everything is taken and so what we
do here is we pick up with Andrea we
pick up with Rick Grimes we pick up with
Spencer and Michonne as they start to
make their way to the hilltop colony but
the problem with this is the last time
they went to the hilltop colony they
were being led by Paul Monroe they're
being led by Jesus this time they're not
and so they kind of have to make their
way there by themselves and because of
this we're actually going to see them
struggling a little bit but in addition
to seeing this happen with Rick Grimes
effectively being the leader some of the
Savior's are sitting on a rooftop and as
soon as their van passes by and leaves
one of the guys tells tells them to
alert negan let me you know that these
guys are on their way and so what we do
is we pick up with Rick and Michonne and
and you know everybody else or I guess
you know Carl and Glenn and Maggie as
they end up having to camp out for the
night some because we're not really lost
so much as we're still trying to find
their way and it's much easier to travel
in the daytime than it is at night
because you can't really see that far
ahead of you and so when they take camp
they basically start going through
setting up
you know setting up basically like a
watch you know each of them takes turns
keeping an eye on what's going on but
when it's Rick Grimes turn to keep an
eye out he's suddenly taken by surprise
he's suddenly taken from behind now
there's something else that I want to
point out here that I actually really
didn't think about mentioning until now
is that Rick Grimes is down a hand now
this doesn't require a great big huge
amount of exposition Rick Grimes had his
hand cut off by the governor you know
during the whole Woodbury situation it's
an interesting dichotomy to see the Rick
Grimes does not have his hand in the in
the comics but he does have it in the TV
show it's not the most significant thing
in fact there was a big story are
dealing with Rick Grimes when he lost
his hand but that has long since passed
and he's basically learned how to cope
with it but I thought it was just
something worth mentioning as we were
going through this video but the fact
remains that when Rick Grimes is taken
from behind when he's taken by surprise
he's brought down and he's faced with
around 50 members of the savior's now
again the saviors are usually around 200
strong so they have a great big huge
camp now they have a huge set up that
will actually see in the future but the
basis behind this is is negan makes his
appearance for the very first time and
what I want to tell you guys right now
is we've only seen a glimpse of negan in
the TV show but if you've got the
feeling that negan was cold blooded and
ruthless you are 100% right negan puts
the governor to shame in terms of how
dark he is and in terms of how cruel he
is his cruelty isn't necessarily in
being overt like he doesn't really
torture people at least in this
situation he doesn't torture them he
doesn't really mutilate them and meat
kills him in brutal ways his
gruesomeness and his darkness is in the
sense that he thinks it's funny that he
thinks it's hilarious that he's killing
people now what we see with negan's
original arrival is almost identical to
what we saw in the TV show and that's
one of the things that I loved so much
there were a couple changes in terms of
phrase of course in the TV show
negan started talking about the New
World Order about how things are you
know and how everything works in the
comics he does almost the exact same
thing you know what he says is that he
wants half of everything that Rick
Grimes has and that if half is too much
then they can steal or they can find or
they can do whatever it is they need to
do make more in order to offset and
it'll it'll cover the difference it's
almost word-for-word with what negan
said in the comic books versus the TV
show but what this does is this also
introduces the character of Lucille
now when I say the character of use of
Lucille I use that phrase loosely and
the reason why is because Meegan talks
about Lucille as if it were a person of
course Lucille is the baseball bat but
one of Megan's signature phrases and one
of the phrases that I love so much so I
imagine some of you are probably saying
right now as you're watching this video
is Lucille is thirsty Lucille is thirsty
is a catchphrase of negan and in The
Walking Dead and there are people that
still say it negan's I guess I'm sorry
Lucille is a barbed wire baseball bat
and she's thirsty because she loves
drinking blood that is to say she loves
being covered in the blood of people
that negan kills and he has killed a lot
of people one of the other reasons why I
say negan is so dark here is because
again tying into this humor tying into
this this element of him that doesn't
really seem to care about what it is
that he does to other people the fact
that he's a psychopath sociopath you
know all different kinds of paths that
uh that ultimately he decides that he
doesn't want to kill Glenn he doesn't
want to kill Michonne and he doesn't
want to kill some of the other members
of the group because it'll make him seem
racist because they're minorities and so
the initial idea here from us is that
he's going to kill Rick Grimes or he's
going to kill one of the kids with Yoko
Karl but ultimately as he starts going
through and he does the whole eenie
meenie miney mo thing he chooses Glenn
and Glenn ends up being the person that
he kills and he does it in I would say
spectacular fashion but also in very
gruesome fashion of course he says you
know you can you can breathe you can
blink you know you can cry you know
you're all gonna be doing that and this
is why I love the first appearance of
negan because of the TV show it was
word-for-word
it was almost word-for-word it was all
you know it was like Jeffrey Dean Morgan
literally just read off the comic
everything that negan said when he first
appeared in the comics and while Glenn
initially begs not to die negan totally
ignores him and starts smashing him in
the head and this is why I say he's so
sadistic because he starts making jokes
about how Glenn's taking it like a champ
you know and he starts saying hey are
you okay are you still in there
you know when he starts making jokes
about how Glenn's one of his eyes is
halfway popping out of his head about
how gross it is now keep in mind the
reason why this was such a big deal when
this first happened is because when it
was Glenn he had been a mainstay
character of the comics for so long and
none of us ever really envisioned a
scenario where Glenn would
I like this especially when you consider
the fact that it's you know in The
Walking Dead comics anybody can die at
any time it really tells you how much we
love to Glenn as a character but not
only that Glenn is a soon-to-be father
Maggie was pregnant you know Maggie is
pregnant with his children and so you
know we expected him to continue on we
expected him to live and even you know
maybe just see the birth of his kids but
he doesn't get that instead negan just
starts smashing his brains into into the
ground and so what Meghan says and this
is one of the reasons why I say that the
fall of negan is almost as spectacular
as an introduction due to the fact that
Rick Grimes mutters to himself that he's
going to kill negan and negan says okay
fine if you if you think you can kill me
then do it right now now there's a
reason why Rick Grimes didn't do this
Rick Grimes could have killed negan he
could have killed him on the spot and he
could have called it a day but negan
calls his bluff
and what negan says is if you kill me
then my savior's are gonna kill you and
they're gonna wipe out Alexandria and
that's exactly what would happen and and
you know Rick Grimes knows this would
happen Rick Grimes knows that if he were
to kill negan right here and right now
yes the Savior's might be a leaderless
for a while but someone would rise up
and take negan's place not only that
with Rick Grimes and his entire crew
being killed no one from the hilltop
colony or the Alexandria safe zone know
what's going on out here Andrea knows
that Rick Grimes went out on a mission
and she would most likely panic if he's
not back in a certain amount of time but
she doesn't know that he's encountering
negan she doesn't know that Lynn's been
killed she has no idea any of that's
happening and so basically if Rick
Grimes were to kill negan the forces of
the Savior's would cut a swath through
the hilltop colony and the Alexandria
safe zone killing pretty much all of
them and taking all those supplies for
their own and so it's in the best
interest of everybody else not really
even Rick Grimes but it's in the best
interest of everybody else for Rick
Grimes to hold his tongue and to let me
and say what he wants to say and then
you know survive the day and plan
accordingly and that's exactly what
happens the group begins the process of
going through and planning out how to
kill negan but with that being said
we're going to go ahead and and bring
this to an end let me know what you guys
think about all this because again you
know this is this is really cool you
know line of stories I mean you know the
the whole something to fear story arc is
incredible in and of itself someone
because the fact that you know once once
Glenn dies Maggie starts freaking out
she attacks Rick Grimes you know
you might as well have killed him
yourself you know why did you let Glenn
die like that you know why couldn't you
do something everybody is it's freaking
out but more so than that they're also
feeding on their anger they're also
outraged to the fact that they've been
made to watch one of their closest
friends killed you know on the concrete
ground of a parking lot you know in the
most dishonorable way possible and so it
basically sets the stage for this future
idea
that the life of negan is going to come
crashing down around him and the forces
of Rick Grimes and his team seem to be
the ones that are going to do it but if
you guys are new here to comics explain
if you guys are new here to my channel
make sure you guys hit the sub button if
you want to see more Walking Dead
content on my channel also make sure you
drop a like and post a comment down
below tell me you know tell me whether
or not you guys want to see more Walking
Dead stuff tell me what you think about
negan I'm really curious you know how do
you guys feel about him as a character
because I got to tell you I am so hyped
for the new season of Walking Dead and I
think I'm calling it now I think this
season premiere is going to be the
most-watched episode the most-watched
season premiere of a TV show in the
history of television I know it's a bold
statement no don't worry that that fact
does not go missed by me I know it is a
bold statement but I think it's going to
be the case because the Walking Dead is
the most-watched television show on on
network television not taking to account
pay channels like HBO that's that
belongs to Game of Thrones but because
of this I think you know people want to
know who it was a negan killed I think
it's gonna be one of the most popular
season premieres of all time but anyway
yeah we're gonna go ahead and wrap this
video up because I could ramble on about
The Walking Dead forever and yeah I will
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]
okay